follow your passion first first first
first first first if I were to ask you
what's your passion do you know the
answer people gave me the same stupid
advice do what you love thank you thanks
you know find your passion
thank you like what am I supposed to do
with that advice in my opinion you have
all been given some terrible advice
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn if you
should or should not follow your passion
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with thought
number one follow your passion first
with Kobe Bryant follow your passion
first first first first first first when
I retired from the game I said they're
asking kind of all the wrong questions
it was the biggest industry I can get
into it's all the wrong stuff and you
got to sit there and ask yourself okay
what am I truly passionate about what do
I enjoy doing and when you feel that way
honestly I mean you feel like you have
never worked a day in your life it's the
most fun thing in the world you get up
in the morning excited about what you're
doing and you got to be really honest
with yourself about it if you wake up in
the morning and you're dreading going to
work dude do something else do something
else and those are hard decisions to
make but when you make those decisions
it's a very liberating experience and
you'll find out that the rewards will
come thought number two follow the
energy with Mel Robbins if I were to ask
you what's your passion do you know the
answer most of you are gonna say oh I
don't know what my passion is and while
we're on the topic of fashion I bet
you're starting to even think how you
even find your passion and when it comes
to finding your passion you're making a
huge mistake you're looking for passion
in the wrong place and it's not your
fault that you're making this mistake
because you were told why you were told
you got to go find your passion
I even remember reading that if you find
your passion you'll never work a day in
your life but here's the problem you've
been led to believe that passion is
something that you find that it's like
some magical career or it's an amazing
person or it's a place that you're gonna
live or it's a pursuit passion
none of those things let me tell you the
problem with thinking that passion is
something that you find when you think
passion is some treasure that's hidden
from you you're gonna spend your whole
life looking for something that's gonna
make you feel lost it's gonna make you
feel overwhelmed it's gonna make you
feel confused so let me show you the way
there's no such thing as finding your
passion you see passion is not something
that you find passion is something that
you feel if you're looking to find it
that thing that you were born to do I
want you to stop looking right now stop
living your life like you're missing
some sort of puzzle piece and if you
just find it then everything is going to
fall into place because passion isn't a
person a place or a thing passion
doesn't exist outside of you you're not
gonna find it in a job you're not gonna
find it on a mountaintop you're not
gonna find it in a relationship you're
not gonna find it online and you're
definitely not gonna find it in a fancy
hotel on the ocean in the Maldives you
want to know where you find it look in
the mirror because passion is just
energy that's it passion is something
you feel passion is not something that
you find passion is the energy you bring
to everything that you're doing that's
all the passion is that's why you can be
miserable making millions on Wall Street
but you can be passionate as hell
directing traffic on a runway for a
fraction of the money because you know
what passion is not what you do it's how
you do it so when somebody says I've
discovered my passion you know what
they're really saying I will energize
when I get up in the morning because I'm
excited about how I show up in my life
and the energy that I feel when I'm
living
my life that's it passion is just energy
thought number three do what you love
with Steve Jobs I'm wondering what would
be the single most valuable piece of
advice you give us to even attempt to
create some of the value that you guys
have done in both your very impressive
companies people say you you have to
have a lot of passion for what you're
doing and it's totally true and the
reason is is because it's so hard that
if you don't any rational person would
give up it's really hard and you have to
do it over a sustained period of time so
if you don't love it if you're not
having fun doing it you don't really
love it you're gonna give up and that's
what happens to most people actually if
you really look at that the ones that
ended up you know being successful
unquote the eyes of society and the ones
that didn't oftentimes it's the ones
that are successful loved what they did
so they could persevere well you know
when it got really tough and and the
ones that didn't love it quit because
they're saying right who would want to
put up with this stuff if you don't love
it so it's a lot of hard work and and
it's a lot of worrying constantly and if
you don't love it you're gonna fail so
you got to love it you got to have
passion also if you want to have more
confidence and self-love check out my
254 series they're free the links to
join under description below everybody
gives too much of a [ __ ] about what
everybody else thinks
and you know who they think the mother
worry the most with the skill to hold
your opinions to yourself until everyone
has spoken does two things
I always did everything back ass half
words you know I like to challenge
myself but number form align yourself
with your beliefs with simon Sinek
the problem with passion you know people
gave me the same stupid advice do what
you love thank you thanks you know find
your passion
thank you like what am I supposed to do
with that advice you know and and what I
learned is is that passion like profit
as a result when we commit ourselves to
some higher purpose some higher cause
passion is the result when we work hard
for something we don't believe in it's
called stress we work hard for something
we do believe in it's called passion
passion is not the entry point is that
the exit point so the question is not to
find your passion or find the thing
you're passionate about the question is
what do you believe the mission is what
are your ideals what are your values and
where are the places in which those
people are those organizations share
your values share your beliefs who is
articulating a vision of a world that
you would like to live in push yourself
in those directions be around those
people you know align yourself with
those organizations and what you will
find is you show up every day with
passion thought number five find your
calling with Jeff Bezos ever since I was
five years old that's when Neil
Armstrong stepped onto the surface of
the Moon I've been kind of passionate
about space rockets rocket engines space
travel I became a science fiction reader
and I've always known that I wanted to
you know do something having to do with
space and I've spent a lot of time
thinking about it for really almost my
whole life and that's one of the things
you guys will find that you have
passions and having a passion is a gift
I think we all have passions and you
don't get to choose them they pick you
but you have to be alert to them you
have to be looking for them and when you
find your passion it's a fantastic gift
for you because it gives you direction
it gives you purpose you could have a
job or you can have a career or you can
have a calling and the
best thing is to have a calling and if
you find your passion you'll have that
and all your work won't feel like work
to you and thought number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
don't follow your passion with micro in
my opinion you have all been given some
terrible advice and that advice is this
follow your passion every time I watch
the Oscars I cringe when some famous
movie star trophy and hand starts to
deconstruct the secret of their success
it's always the same thing don't let
anyone tell you that you don't have what
it takes kid and the ever-popular
never give up on your dreams look I
understand the importance of persistence
and the value of encouragement but who
tells a stranger to never give up on
their dreams without even knowing what
it is they're dreaming I mean how can
Lady gaga possibly know where your
passion will lead you have these people
never seen American Idol year after year
thousands of aspiring American idols
show up with great expectations only to
learn that they don't possess the skills
they thought they did what's really
amazing though is not their lack of
talent world's full of people who can't
sing it's their genuine shock at being
rejected the incredible realization that
their passion and their ability had
nothing to do with each other
look if we're talking about your hobby
by all means let your passion lead you
but when it comes to making a living
it's easy to forget the dirty truth just
because you're passionate about
something doesn't mean you won't suck at
it
and just because you've earned a degree
in your chosen field it doesn't mean
you're gonna find your dream job dream
jobs are usually just that dreams but
they're imaginary existence just might
keep you from exploring careers that
offer a legitimate chance to perform
meaningful work and develop a genuine
passion for the job you already have
when I was 16 I wanted to follow in my
grand father's footsteps he was a
skilled tradesman could build a house
without a blueprint that was my passion
and I followed it for years I took all
the shop classes
school I did all I could to absorb the
knowledge and skill that came so easily
to my granddad
unfortunately the handy gene is
recessive it skipped right over me and I
struggled mightily to overcome my
deficiencies but I couldn't I was one of
those contestants on American Idol who
believed his passion was enough to
ensure his success
one day I brought home a sconce I had
made in wood shop looked like a
Paramecium after a heavy sigh my
granddad gave me the best advice I've
ever received he told me Mike you can
still be a tradesman but only if you get
yourself a different kind of toolbox at
the time this felt contrary to
everything I believed about the
importance of passion and persistence
and staying the course but of course he
was right because staying the course
that only makes sense if you're headed
in a sensible direction and while
passion is way too important to be
without it is way too fickle to follow
around which brings us to the final
dirty truth never follow your passion
but always bring it with you now I have
a special bonus clip with Mark Cuban on
how to follow your effort that I think
you can enjoy but before that I want to
know what's your take is it the best
advice to follow or the worst give me
your two cents
put it down the comments below when you
find something you're good at yeah go
for it and I also also always say it's
not about passion
everybody's got passion for something
yeah right don't follow your passions
follow your efforts because people say
you know I was passionate to play
baseball I was passionate to play
basketball doesn't mean out all the
sudden I was going to be good enough
yeah but I found myself spending being
really curious about business being
really curious about technology and that
curiosity is really what drove me and I
think particularly if you're young today
curiosity is great always learning and
trying to find new things and being
curious about new things because that's
what leads you to that path trying to
figure out in advance yeah that's hard
because you don't know what you don't
know I was
were really into technology when I was a
kid but then as I got a job that used it
I found out I was good at it and once I
found out I was good at it then it
became a lot more fun yeah you know when
you're good at something it's almost
always fun yeah and once it was fun and
I combined that with you know my
business skills then I saw okay I know
how to make money at this stuff because
I know how to sell now I know tech that
gives me something I love to do and so
you know what I oh I tell people the key
is find something you love to do and be
great at it
yeah because once you do that it's all
gravy
[Music]
if you want to know how to attract
success in 2020 check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there I want to explain
something to you that not many people
really understand I want to talk about
the law of attraction